welcome back everybody a family game of
Monopoly in Oklahoma turns violent
police say John Armstrong and his family
were drinking and paying playing
Monopoly on Saturday when Armstrong got
into a fight with his stepfather and
that escalated to the game board being
flipped over and Furniture being knocked
around when they took the fight outside
Armstrong steps this stepsister says
that he fired a shot at her and her
father as they tried to run away
Armstrong told adults police as he was
being arrested that he fired one shot at
the ground Brian extended family alcohol
competition can sometimes be a very
volatile combo as we clearly see here
yeah go to jail don't pass go don't
collect 200 that famous Monopoly chance
card was the first thing I thought about
when I heard about this arrest Monopoly
has tested relationships built alliances
and destroyed friendships but assault
with a deadly weapon is a new one for me
but as I read more about the case I
think there may actually be a defense
depending on how the evidence pans out
we don't have all of the facts yet but
hear me out before you judge a woman
calls 9-1-1 saying her stepbrother shot
at her and her father after a Monopoly
game all of them drinking so we don't
know how much or who was drunk or who
may be protecting Hoon furniture and the
board flipped over like you said and
they Take It Outside they almost agree
to go fight outside now John Armstrong
the suspect is said to have fired at The
Stepfather after getting cut in the head
but who cut him where'd the knife come
from who brought a knife to a fist fight
and how bad was that injury because to
me it sounds like that self-defense from
deadly force if he pulls out a gun now
Armstrong says he's shot at the ground
but that brings up other questions
where's the shell casing is there
evidence of an indent in the ground
where he shot also no gun found do they
test anyone's hands for gunshot residue
now Armstrong may have landed on the
blue property and found himself in a lot
of trouble but I don't think this case
is as open and shut as one may think
Monopoly puns aside I think this case is
worth another roll of the dice before we
find out who's guilty or not I'm not
gonna lie Brian that was a nice touch
that was a really nice nice touch but
getting a little serious he is charged
with assault with a deadly weapon Terry
what is that what kind of penalty could
he face well we're in Oklahoma here so
assault with a deadly weapon is if you
intentionally try to injure someone but
you're not trying to kill them and the
deadly weapon part also has an intent
component is he trying to kill with that
weapon or is he just trying to you know
frighten someone and not really kill
them and here depending on what comes
out with all the facts he's saying he
shot at the ground they are saying that
he was shooting at them and depending on
how ultimately if this goes to trial he
could serve up to 10 years one to ten
years and so it's a very serious charge
and you know they're looking at it like
he obviously should not have been using
that weapon the way he used it against
his own family members which is really
odd to say that you know you could do
something like that when it's your
father and your stepsister obviously you
have domestic violence cases but I
wouldn't have thought that a Monopoly
game would end up with a shooting as we
just saw yeah I wouldn't have imagined
that either Terry and real quick 10
seconds I mean you said between one and
ten years what how does that usually
work you think it'll be somewhere down
the middle yeah I think it will be here
I don't think he's going to go to jail
for uh 10 years at all I mean if no one
was injured if in fact that bullet did
go on the ground and he wasn't trying to
aim it at them or to hurt them at all I
think he'll get the Lesser side of that
I think the main lesson is Candyland
would have probably been the better
option uh Monopoly very tense you know I
clearly it brings out the worst in all
of us Brian Terry thank you so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here once again on Long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
thank you